good morning and thank you for your
interest in our work so i would have a
take a few minutes to guide you through
our poster on the validation of our HT
GHz platform for accurate insensitive
biomarker discovery so first of all let
me introduce myself so I'm Sabrina
Tanana and i work at ferraris leading
group in biomarker discovery and
qualification our group is a focusing
mainly on a biomarker discovery in
qualification for clinical applications
and we cover every step in our
activities from matter discovery to
market so for this we cover we have a
lot of bio analytical platforms and
facilities for assay development of
prediction all in a eyes or certified
environment and we also intervene at
other steps like data analyzes and
regulatory affairs so for this biomarker
development so we use a lot of status or
at tools that we use for prone proof
providing at the proteomic levels but so
for metabolomic and epidemic providing
and gene expression and that's the
little point on which we are going to
produce with our HTG ethnic platform so
talking about these technologies it has
major advantageous that we will talk
about the first one is that this method
is a extraction free with which
eliminates the ladies from RNA
extractions and it also allows to work
with really minimal simple input
requirements so as you can see on the
table we can work with this technology
with as low as 15 microliters of plasma
from patient sample
and we also can use other types like
bath change n hele natives or frozen
tissue send lines and also ffp tissues
which can be really interesting for all
studies so looking at the chemistry of
this technology is it is bathed on a
nucleus protection probe as a so
basically how it works if that in panels
we use there will be a protection probe
specific for each target we are looking
for and this process are coupled two
little wings arms and we'll put will
bind with women and target RNA after
this we will have a digestion based on
the activity of the s1 nuclease that
will digest all inbound RNA and poles
and a second type step of idolizes will
eliminate targets are already so at this
step we will have only the protection
probes left that we're bound to target
RNA and this probes are the ones that we
are going going to quantify so in the
first step we will add adapters with
barcode by pcr and then these fragments
will be ready for sequencing so to
resume this technology you can see here
the workflow how it works so we are just
starting from samples that we prepare to
to put in the HTG processor and in this
process or the step one two three of the
chemistry will will happen so it will
take around 20 hours and we will be able
to process a 96 sample at one in once at
one time after this run we will simply
add barcodes by pcr and quantify or
liberally and then we will sequence it
through next-generation sequencing after
the run
simply by returning the first 25 we will
process them in a HTG pass or software
and we will have a result count for each
RNA that were targeted by the panel so
in with this experiment we can look at
up to 2500 targets in one sandbox so
with this technology we have various
panels available as you can see here in
the bottom we have a panel available for
oncology biomarkers so that the ma ma I
need panel which consists of 2560 genes
belonging to 24 groups in pathways
relevant in oncology there's also a
liminal uncle drug response panel that
as targets little less jeans around five
hundred forty and four other diseases we
also have for example the lymphoma
associated genus a now this technology
not only allows to to look for gene
expression and mrna level but also at
non-coding RNA like micro RNAs and there
is a work from scriptum I say that they
text 200 2048 Mira knees at one time and
that is the panel we use to validate or
platform on our side so what we did for
validation is two different things the
first one was to compare this technique
with another one the qpcr xicans me Rene
Pinnell so we processed eight samples in
duplicate so with this post method and
as you can see here under graph we saw
that there was a really good correlation
between unme RNA expression which is
both methods the other thing we did was
to look for our HTG reproducibility so I
wonder samples while you are process
four times three times in the US by HTG
molecular that developed these
technologies on different days operators
instrument and one time by us in outside
entrance and as you can see on the shots
presented here is that between all the
sets we are the really good correlations
of the results with accommodations being
over zero point ninety-nine so this
shows that as this technique is really
really simple and that the extraction
free process is an advantage so and
lastly to conclude I want to present you
a little example of a study where we use
this me Rene Pinnell so this study at
the purpose of validating a mere when a
signature that was previously identified
as predictive and we realized the study
with 15 microliters of a plasma from 75
patients that had negative outcome for
disease and compared it with 67 patients
with positive outcome and so with this
kid with creamed all the 2,000 me RNA
and there are so 24 controls with this
HTG technology and as a result we
identified 313 micrornas that were above
a quantitative threshold and we could
confirm that previously identified me
Renee's other the predicate value and we
have to reach a predictive model with a
sensitivity of zeros 74 so to conclude I
we saw that this HCG epic platform
offers really cost-effective and
readable and the is a real reliable tool
for accurate and sensitive RNA
measurement and it is a really
invaluable tool for DOMA
discovery thanks to its low simple input
requirements and its extraction free
process so I think you for your
intention and i hope you enjoyed it
thank you